Now that you've seen some SWF types
let's move on to simple operations.
We'll start with comparison operators.
Let's say my little cousin Chloe
gets an allowance every week.
With her allowance she likes to get
ice cream and go to the movies.
By the way, I'm going to use a lot of
if statements and these operations.
For now just become accustomed
to how the if statements look.
And stay tuned for
more practice writing if statements
in the lesson on control flow.
If she gets soft serve for
$1.50 everything is all good.
She can get ice cream and
go to the movies.
But if Chloe goes to the fancy ice
cream place, the calculation changes.
If we wanted to condition on the case
that she has just enough allowance,
we could use the equals operator.
But of course, it makes more sense to
condition on her having greater than or
equal to the combined price.
Now, let's look at
the logical operators.
Here, I've defined some
variables as bulls and
allowed the compiler
to infer their type.
When conditioning on a bull,
you just type the variable name.
And more for both languages you might
have to type something like equals true.
But that's not necessary in swift.
So here if hungriest true, let's eat.
Otherwise, we can wait until later.
If we want to reverse the condition,
we just throw in an exclamation
point indicating not before hungry.
Here, you can see the and operator.
If hungry is true and
vegetarian is false, let's eat steak.
I must admit, I have a hard time
passing up a juicy rib-eye.
But if hungry is true and vegetarian is
also true, let's go for a pumpkin curry.
If neither is true, then never mind.
Now there are a few cases in which
hunger is not a necessary condition for
eating.
And for me,
that would be when there is pie.
Here you can see the or operator.
So here, if hungry is true or
thereIsPie is true Let's see.
Now I'm sure comparison operators and
logical operators are a piece
of cake for most of you.
The ternary conditional operator
is a little less intuitive.
But it can be super convenient
once you get the hang of it.
Apple summarizes turn airy
conditionals nicely in the book
Swift programming language,
using this theoretical example.
Here if question is true then
the result is answer one.
Otherwise, there result is answer two.
So the previous examples
could be written as follows.
If hungry is true, let's eat.
Otherwise, let's wait.
If hungry is true, or
there is pie, let's eat.
Otherwise, let's wait.
As you can imagine, this syntax is
really convenient with short, simple
conditions but can become a come hard to
read as your conditions become longer or
more complex.
This syntax is especially handy for
calculations with conditions,
like this one.
There is one thing that a ternary
operator can do that in
if else statement cannot.
The entire ternary
statement is an expression.
It evaluates to a single value.
So we can insinuate it right into
another expression like this.
So the lunch price is now calculated
using the sandwich price.
And if tax is true,
we'll add an additional $.50.
Otherwise we'll add nothing.